everybody it's gary vaynerchuck is how i
go these days um white companies have a
need to say we'll go there when it's
ready why are so many people saying well
I'm get it and we see it but it's not
real now so we'll see you there in two
years that weaving period I'm not
getting involved in trends is how you go
out of business and this whole you know
when that gets bigger or will be there
is insanity have you never heard of
practice makes perfect
have you never heard of you know the
fact that trends you want to be part of
the wave instead of showing up and
having the wave crashed down and break
your face and put you out of business it
baffles my mind to no degree to the
biggest degree excuse me that companies
don't understand my getting involved in
web 2.0 because that's my new thing I'm
not gonna call it social media because I
was really just go buck 202 minutes ago
whatever you want to call it the new
business platforms as I like to think of
them to not get involved and engaged to
not shake hands to not build a presence
and not to listen and get involved with
your customers is insanity whether
you're a consumer brands product a
sports franchise a retailer b2b who do
you think makes decisions and b2b people
people do so this whole I'll wait to its
real scenario is insanity stupidity and
it's what takes companies and puts them
into the double zero the Robert Parish
zone it puts them out of business you
need to get involved now and grow into
it you don't just go to senior high
school your first year schooling you
need to get involved you think if you're
not and the longer you wait the more
land grabbing
eyeball grabbing business grabbing your
competition is getting